joe biden proposes a six trillion dollar
budget that would sink the economy and
raise the national debt to record levels
the biden white house continues to
foster wokeness in america's
military-industrial complex and
the biden administration decides to take
china's word for it on the origins of
coven 19. i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben okay let's be real about this you're
paying way too much money for your cell
phone i mean right now your cell phone
coverage is costing you way
too much money why well because the big
cell phone coverage providers they fib
to you they don't really tell you what
you're getting or they tell you that you
need
things like unlimited data well you
don't need unlimited data instead what
if you could get the same exact coverage
as one of those big networks
but spend like a fraction of the cost
instead you should switch over to pure
talk usa
switching over to pure talk saves the
average family of four over 800
a year here's the best part you don't
have to sacrifice coverage because it's
on the exact same network as one of the
big providers
switching is super simple you can keep
your phone keep your number or you can
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids that's what i did right now
you can get unlimited talk text in six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and what happens if you go over on the
data i know you're asking that well
they're not going to charge you for it
you have nothing to lose
it's just one of the many reasons pure
talk usa has been named the top
wireless provider by consumer affairs so
get started by
using your cell phone to dial pound 250
say ben shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero say ben shapiro to get
started once again dial pound 250 say
ben shapiro you'll save 50
off your first month and hundreds of
bucks down the road dial pound to 50 ben
shapiro this is
pure talk usa okay so joe biden breaking
news
has now proposed a six trillion dollar
budget
a six trillion dollar budget
um that's insane so just to get this
straight
in his first six months he has now
proposed
a two trillion dollar stimulus plan okay
which actually got passed
he has proposed a two trillion dollar
infrastructure plan that has not yet
been passed he's proposed a two trillion
dollar
american families plan which has not yet
been passed and now a six trillion
dollar budget
which is 12 trillion dollars the entire
gdp of the united states in 2019 was 21
trillion
the highest levels that we have spent in
terms of spending to government spending
to gdp ratio
in in the past like decade we you're
looking at from 2015 and forward
it's like 35 okay now you're talking
about spending well in excess of 50
of gdp again people are like well yeah
but that's just spending this year i
mean
next year i mean that's he's not going
to spend all that this year that's
tranched out over 15 right but then he's
going to propose a six trillion
dollar budget next year as we have seen
once the ratchet moves in one direction
and never moves back down
okay the reality of the situation is
that once barack obama created the four
trillion dollar budget
every single year we've had a four
trillion dollar budget including under
donald trump that became the new normal
so now we are going to increase the
american budget by 50 percent joe biden
wants
50 in the middle of an inflationary
cycle
it's insane it's crazy but after all
i'm not sure joe biden knows what's
going on he numbers confuse him
at this point they probably always did
but now he's super confused about them
because like regular household objects
confuse the president of the united
states at this point
in his career according to the new york
times president biden will propose a six
trillion dollar budget on friday that
would take the united states to its
highest sustained levels of federal
spending
since world war ii while running
deficits above 1.3 trillion dollars
for the next decade for the next decade
so he wants to add
make that calculation yourself 13
trillion dollars minimum
to the national debt over the next
decade the national debt
right now in the united states
is if you if you included things like
you know unfunded liabilities like 132
trillion dollars but if you're just
looking at the published national debt
right now the published national debt
right now in the united states is like
28.3 trillion dollars
joe biden is proposing he's proposing
this to add over the next decade
13 trillion dollars to the national debt
and you know that's way too low you know
it's gonna be higher than that
if he got what he wanted so he's talking
about adding like 50
to the national debt who the hell is
going to buy an american bond why in the
world would you buy an american bond to
fund that
bitcoin of the moon gang as one of our
producers said earlier bitcoin to the
moon
documents obtained by the new york times
show that mr biden's first budget
request is president calls for the
federal government to spend
six trillion dollars in the 2022 fiscal
year
and for total spending to rise to 8.2
trillion dollars by 2031.
and again he ain't gonna be present in
2031. so if he wants the total spending
to rise to 8.2 trillion you're really
talking about
rising a lot more than that the growth
is driven by biden's two-part agenda to
upgrade the nation's infrastructure and
substantially expand the social safety
net contained
in his american jobs plan and american
families plan along with other planned
increases in discretionary spending
the proposal shows the sweep of mr
biden's ambitions to wield government
power
to help more americans attain the
comforts of a middle-class life and to
lift u.s industry to better compete
globally i love that
i love how the new york times is just
let's just read right off of joe biden's
press release right here you know
sure we're going to blow out the debt to
an unprecedented degree this is not a
war okay we're not in the middle of war
time this isn't world war ii
see during world war ii we had to spend
a lot of money because you know we were
in the middle of a
world war in which we were fighting a
two-front gigantic war
one against the axis powers in germany
and in the atlantic and another where we
were fighting another
entirely separate war in the pacific
that's a good reason to blow out the
federal spending is because you're in an
existential war with fascist powers you
know it's a bad reason to blow out the
spending because joe biden
can't control his metamucil that's a
real bad reason to blow out the spending
because joe biden needs his legacy
before he puts in for time at the
nursing home
what in the actual f but the new york
times like well you know but
look at his ambition his the code word
by the way in the media
when somebody proposes something
absolutely insane
but it comports with kind of leftist
priorities then they just say it's
ambitious
it's bold it's ambitious sure he's not
going to get any of this stuff because
frankly he doesn't have the votes in the
senate but but he can i mean
i don't think that you're going to see
manchin or cinema move along with us
on the democratic side of the aisle let
alone getting to the filibuster-proof
majority
you could use reconciliation to pass the
budget but i can't imagine he gets this
through but
if he did that's not ambitious that's
crazy but according to the new york
times don't worry
he's trying to help more americans
attain the comforts of a middle-class
life
the first of all the insanity of
suggesting that america is a place where
you can't attain a middle-class life
that's so crazy
before the pandemic the unemployment
rate in the united states was 3.6
okay we had historically low
unemployment we had historically high
wage growth
and studies demonstrate that if you wish
to attain that middle-class lifestyle in
the united states you need to do
three things and three things only and
all of them if you are mentally capable
are not that hard one is graduating high
school which in the united states
basically means you need to be able to
write your name
not well just like a little okay two
you need to get a job in a country that
has more job openings than people
seeking jobs
again not super difficult so long as you
put your
as you put your shoulder to the to the
millstone to the grindstone
and three don't have babies before
you're married those that's it
those three things and you will not live
in poverty in the united states but
according to joe biden we need to blow
out the budget to the tune of a
1.3 trillion debt for the next 10 years
every year in order to attain a
middle-class lifestyle
because nothing says middle-class
lifestyle quite like complete
redistribution
of wealth by punishing
entrepreneurialism perfect
also he's going to help the united
states better compete globally in the
econ
what in the world so blowing out
spending is going to help us compete
better in the global economy
explain how seriously explain how
you know in sweden they tried in the
1960s 70s they tried something called
the third way the third way in sweden
was it was an attempt to blow out the
spending in democratic socialist fashion
it completely sunk their economy and
they had to walk back their social
spending and taxation rates
joe biden's like well let's forget about
all that let's just do it man it'll make
us more competitive
more competitive again before kovid the
united states had the most dominant
economy on planet earth by a
long stretch not close and john's like
well forget all of that
mr biden's plans to fund his agenda by
raising taxes on corporations and higher
earners
would begin to shrink budget deficits in
the 2030s okay which means it's never
going to shrink budget deficits but
i mean this is literally i'll buy a
hamburger today and i will pay for it
30 years from now no you won't it'll
shrink budget deficits
in the 2030s now i may be
out of line here but i check the
calendar like right now
and the calendar says it is now 2021.
if joe biden says oh yeah long after i'm
dead
we're gonna shrink the budget deficit if
you believe this you are a stupid person
if you believe that he's gonna blow it
like he's he's admitting that he's
blowing out the deficit
at 1.3 trillion dollars a year for the
next decade every year
but don't worry guys when you get to
2031 when by the way
joe biden will be i counted in his late
80s
if he is still alive okay joe biden
right now
is age 78 he'll be 88 he's like oh well
you know when i'm 88 years old
i'm 78 now when i'm 88 years old then
we'll start to lower the deficit
sure administration officials say the
jobs and families plan would be fully
offset by tax increases over the course
of 15 years
and this budget request backs it up no
it's the spending is over 10.
again you're not even using the same
length of time
that's like saying you know i'm gonna
blow out my credit card this month
i'm gonna spend like a million dollars
on my credit card this month but
probably over the course of the next 10
years
i might earn 10 million dollars yes but
the spending is happening now
what are you even talking about you have
to use the same time period for the
spending
and the taxation in order to make those
numbers match
how do you even play that game in the
meantime the united states would run
significant deficits as it borrows money
to finance his plans
under mr biden's proposal the federal
budget deficit would hit 1.8 trillion
dollars in 2022
even as the economy rebounds from the
pandemic recession to grow at what the
administration predicts would be its
fastest annual pace since the early
1980s
so first of all we shouldn't be growing
our fastest annual pace since the early
1980s
we should theoretically be growing at
our fastest annual pace ever why because
we had the greatest artificial recession
in american history last year
talk about playing with statistics like
look how fast the economy is growing
well yes when you forcibly kill tens of
millions of jobs
by telling people they can't go to work
then when they can go back to work the
economy will grow
wow that's like a shocking statistic
this is like saying
you know bob today he had his most uh
the transition like his energy level the
difference between the morning and
evening
and his energy level today was the
highest change ever
now what i'm not going to tell you is
that we had bob in an artificial coma
until this morning so the difference
between artificial coma and him just
like drinking a cup of coffee that's
like a thousand percent difference that
is such an unbelievable energy but you
just don't tell people that
what it depends what you use as the
baseline
yes it's true that if you use as the
baseline the economic statistics from
the middle of a pandemic
then we have very high growth rates
it would recede slightly in the
following years before growing against
nearly 1.6 trillion dollars by 2031.
total debt held by the public would more
than exceed the annual value of economic
output
rising to 117 percent of the size of the
economy
in 2031. by 2024
debt as a share of the economy would
rise to its highest level in american
history
eclipsing its world war ii era record
for what for what
what are you even talking about why
honestly god why
right now he's saying we're predicting
the greatest american economic growth
since the 1980s
you know what we should do what if we
just spend a load of money for no reason
at all
what if we blow out the debt to the tune
of the worst
debt as a share of the economy ever
like including world war ii when we were
fighting world wars and had mobilized
the entire
male civilian population between the
ages of 18 and 40 and put them in
barracks
what in the i mean this is it's totally
crazy and the media
is like well you know well he is trying
to shore up that middle class oh you
mean the middle class that ended this
year with more savings than it had last
year thanks to government largesse
according to the new york times the
levels of taxation and spending in mr
biden's plans would expand the federal
fiscal footprint to levels
rarely seen in the post-war era rarely
never to fund investments that his
administration says are crucial to
keeping america competitive
that includes money for roads i love
that it's about roads guys are spending
six trillion dollars
for roads no
or not again if you believe this you're
a stupid
stupid man stupid
it includes money for roads water pipes
broadband internet electric vehicle
charging stations and advanced
manufacturing research okay you know
what that's gonna comprise
like this percent of the budget like as
a percentage of that total six trillion
dollar budget it was
like that that kind of stuff was like
five to ten percent of the
infrastructure plan that was a true
trillion dollar plan this is a six
trillion dollar plan
it also envisions funding for affordable
childcare universal pre-k a national
paid leave program and a host of other
initiatives
spending on national defense would also
grow though though it would decline as a
share of the economy we'll get to
national defense in just a second
because
the biden administration is continuing
its quest to wokify the military
the documents suggest mr biden will not
propose major additional policies in the
budget
or that his budget will flesh out plans
that the administration has thus far
declined to detail for example
biden pledged to overhaul and upgrade
the nation's unemployment insurance
program as part of the american family's
plans
but such efforts are not included in his
budget right that's a separate plan
that he's still proposing the budget is
simply a request to congress which must
approve federal spending both democrats
in control of both chambers of congress
biden faces some of the best odds of any
president in recent history
in having much of his agenda approved
particularly if he can reach agreement
with lawmakers on parts of his
infrastructure agenda
if mr biden's plans were enacted again
this is the new york times i love how
they bury the lead here
if mr biden's plans were enacted the
government would spend what amounts to
nearly a quarter of the nation's total
economic output
every year over the course of the next
decade
it would collect tax revenues equal to
just under one-fifth of the total
economy
how are they going to make up that
difference by selling your bonds of
course by selling bonds to china
or by having the federal reserve
essentially manufacture money
in order to pay for all of this in each
year of biden's budget the government
would spend more as a share of the
economy than all but two years since
world war ii
2020 and 2021 which is because we blew
out the budget
in order to shore up the pandemic
response by the way
who thinks that his budget is gonna be
his total spending which president has
the budget been the only budgetary
move that's been made over the course of
the year this is this is madness
by 2028 the government would be
collecting more tax revenue as a share
of the economy than almost any point in
modern statistical history
the documents also show the conservative
approach biden's economic team is taking
with regard to projecting the economy's
growth biden's aides predicted even if
his full agenda were enacted the economy
would grow at just under two percent
for most of the decade after accounting
for inflation which is sluggish
i mean at least they're being realistic
about that he will produce sluggish
growth
unemployment would fall to 4.1 percent
by next year from 6.1 percent today and
remain below 4
in the years thereafter oh would it
really as you inflate all the prices by
blowing money into the economy
do you think that unemployment that
people continue to hire at extraordinary
rates
and this is this is ridiculous the biden
forecast continues to show his
administration has little fear of rap
and inflation breaking out across the
economy
despite recent data showing a quick jump
in prices under the biden team's
projections consumer prices never rise
faster than 2.3
per year well weird because year on year
according to the last
available metric the inflation was like
4.2 percent like twice
almost twice that biden says that now is
a great time
because the interest rates are low for
us to basically just blow money into the
economy
which is actually a terrible time to
blow money into the economy because that
creates bubbles
i love this interest rates are
controlled by the federal reserve which
is independence of the white house yeah
super independent
super independents over at that federal
reserve you know who was running the
federal reserve until five seconds ago
janet yellen who's currently the
secretary of the treasury under wait for
it
president house plant even if the
interests stay low
interest rates stay low payments on the
national debt would consume an increased
share of the federal budget
net interest payments would double as a
share of the economy from 2022 to 2031.
okay this is it's just insane it's just
insane
okay so his plan is to blow out the
spending in the middle
of a natural economic recovery and in
the middle of an inflationary spiral
in order to do what he wants his legacy
here's the bottom line he wants his
legacy
that guy knows he's not running for
reelection he wants to be a
consequential president and therefore
he's just going to blow out the spending
because who cares
somebody else is gonna have to deal with
that down the line
unreal and it also it's incredible that
supposedly
if you confiscate 25 of the american gdp
every year from taxpayers which by the
way is a minimum it'll be more
if he does that then that's gonna have
no impact on gdp growth which will
continue to grow steadily at two percent
and inflation which will continue to
just be two percent a year it's just
nuts i'm sorry this is fantasyland
bullcrap
we all get what we deserve if we decide
to go forward with this seriously okay
in just a second
we'll get to joe biden's plans for the
military because
our military unpreparedness is growing
because we continue to locify the
military we'll get to that in just one
second first
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix sleep mattress
it's the only thing that allows me to
operate on a day-to-day basis because my
kids wake me up at all hours of the
night
now i have more exciting news helix has
gone beyond the boudoir they've started
making sofas
yes they launched a new company called
all form all form is making premium
customizable sofas
and chairs shipped right to your door so
what makes an all form sofa really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores
you can pick your fabric it is spill
stain scratch resistant the sofa color
the color of the leg sofa size and shape
make sure it's perfect for you and your
home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
and you can always start small and buy
more seats later on if you want your
all-form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your door in the past
if you wanted to order a sofa you would
need to hire someone to come and
assemble it in your home or break your
back trying to put it together yourself
not so with all form
simple quick assembly no tools needed i
have it all formed sofa it's so
unbelievably comfortable it is
incredibly durable as well which is
great because i have kids
they have a forever warranty you get 100
days to decide if you want to keep it
and again if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund so you've got nothing to lose
check out allform.com right now all form
is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
again that is allform.com go check them
out
right now allform.com ben
alrighty meanwhile the biden
administration continues to wokify
the nation's military-industrial complex
so
the truth is that the government has
been engaging
in woke in woke priorities with regard
to national defense
for quite a while now the the gao
the us government's accountability
office put out a report in 2017
in which they openly talk about the fact
that the department of defense
actually obligates billions of dollars
every single year
to buy products and services from types
of businesses
okay and a business is according to the
gao a business generally must
self-identify as a minority-owned
business
or a women-owned business as applicable
in the federal government's contractor
registry
so there's like a specific part of the
budget that is basically dedicated that
it has to
be given to a female or minority owned
business now i don't know about you
but when i think about the military
making missiles for example
or making military hardware for jets i
don't care
at all who owns the businesses that sell
that product to the department of
defense i just want that
stuff to work and i want to pay the
lowest price for it because it's coming
in taxpayer expense
but the us government for a very long
time has been engaged in this sort of
affirmative action program
for female owned businesses and and
black owned businesses
designed to direct money toward specific
i mean
by in violation of civil rights law
they they've picked specifically
minority-owned businesses in order to
direct dollars toward those businesses
even if it's a greater cost to taxpayers
even if it means that there's a delay in
the procurement process because you have
to actually demonstrate apparently
that you couldn't have gotten it from a
black owned or a minority or a minority
or female owned business
in order to actually procure certain
military parties what i'm hearing from
people inside the defense department
okay so that's been going on for quite a
while and joe biden was set to ramp that
into high gear
according to governmentexecutive.com
this is back in 2020.
the oncoming biden administration is
likely to increase contracting
opportunities for small and minority
owned businesses
president biden elect said that he wants
to use equity as a guide
andy how our partner in the law from
austin and byrd's government contracts
group says i think we're going to see
more regulation generally promoting
competition
and furthering the socio-economic
policies of the new administration which
is different in many respects from the
current administration
apparently this there was speculation
early on that the biden
team is now effectuating that would
expand
the small business administration's
small business development program to
increase participation of small
disadvantaged firms require prime
contractors to increase subcontracting
opportunities for small disadvantaged
businesses
and protect small business from contract
from contact bundling
because that would prevent smaller firms
especially those owned by black and
brown people from effectively bidding on
procurement
contracts now contract bundling is
generally a good thing because
that means that you have like a defense
let's say lockheed martin they have a
subcontractor and now lockheed martin
wants that subcontractor to go out and
get a bunch of parts well now you're
going to have regulations inside the
biden administration to prevent them
from doing that instead they have to buy
every part separately
and show that every single part could
not have been obtained from a black
owned or female-owned business
before they can just go over to walmart
and pick up the part how that helps
america's military readiness is
absolutely beyond me
it has nothing to do with america's
military resident military
readiness especially in a time of rising
conflict with states like china
but beyond that we have now decided that
it's very important
that america's defense contractors get
engaged with the new woke military
priorities of the biden administration
there's a reason the biden
administration is putting out these
bizarre ads in which they're recruiting
for the cia by being like
here is a a cisgender but very tolerant
hispanic woman with generalized anxiety
disorder you too can work for the cio or
here is a military recruiting ad this
person had two
lesbian moms like what in the world well
again this is about wokifying the
american military and turning it
from what is a quote unquote de facto
right-wing institution into something
that is much more
woke well now this is being crammed down
on america's
contracting companies things like
lockheed martin for example
so christopher ruffo does excellent work
on this sort of stuff
he has a piece today in city journal
says last year lockheed martin
corporation the nation's largest defense
contractor
sent white male executives to a
three-day diversity training program
aimed at deconstructing their white male
culture and encouraging them to atone
for their white male privilege
the program hosted on zoom for a cohort
of 13 lockheed employees was led
by the diversity consulting firm white
men as full diversity partners
which specializes in helping white males
awaken together
which frankly sounds a little creepy
like i wouldn't want to awaken
with a bunch of other white males it's
weird
i i'm married and the lockheed employees
all senior leaders in the company
included aaron huckabee director of
global supply chain operations retired
air force lieutenant colonel david starr
director of the hercules c-130 military
transport program retired air force
lieutenant general bruce
litchfield vice president of sustainment
operations and glenn woods
vice president of production for the air
force's 1.7 trillion dollar f-35
fighter jet program at the beginning of
the program the diversity trainers led a
free association exercise
asking the lockheed employees to list
connotations for the terms
white men the trainers wrote down old
racist
privileged anti-women angry aryan nation
kkk
founding fathers guns guilty and can't
jump
according to the participants these
perceptions have led to assumptions
about white men and diversity with many
employees believing
that white men don't care about
diversity have a classical perspective
on history and colonialism and don't
want to give away our power
the white man's full diversity partners
team jim morris mark haven's michael
welp
framed the purpose of the training
session as providing a benefit for white
men who embrace the diversity and
inclusion philosophy
in response to a prompt about what's in
it for white men the participants listed
benefits such as
i won't get replaced by someone who is a
better full diversity partner
i will improve i will improve the brand
image reputation of white men
and i will have a less nagging sense of
guilt that i am the problem
the firm's founders welp and bill
proudman have argued that white males
must work harder to understand their
white privilege
male privilege and heterosexual
privilege which affords them unearned
benefits this is what we're now
teaching people at lockheed martin now
why exactly is lockheed martin doing
this
why are they bothering the reason
they're doing this is because they want
to be able to say to the biden defense
department
we have complied with all of your woke
dick tots we are on the team guys
keep directing those trillion dollar
checks over here please
this is not the first time that white
men as full diversity partners has been
involved in a controversial training
program
last year the company's white male
training program for employees at sanzia
national laboratories was was performed
consultants such as white men as full
diversity partners are peddling this
sort of stuff to bloated government
contractors
and the government contractors are going
right along with it because of course
they want the contract
so walkifying america's military
industrial complex it is a move
is a shocking move republicans right now
are warning of this
30 house republicans have now sent a
letter to defense secretary lloyd austin
warning him that creeping left-wing
extremism and politicization is
jeopardizing the us's military status
according to breitbart news and
christina wong reporting
the letter led by representative matt
rosendale uh republican montana said we
right to express our concern about the
growing trend of left-wing
extremism and politicization of our
armed forces the military's long history
of standing above politics has made it
one of the most respected institutions
in america
that legacy is now in jeopardy they
listed some examples of politicization
first was the diversity and inclusion
strategic plan for our special forces
the united states army also released a
recruitment video
describing marching and left-wing social
protests as defending freedom and
depicting two moms raising a child and
featured a lesbian at a wedding
lieutenant colonel matt matthew
loehmeyer commander of the 11th space
warning squadron at buckley air force
warned of radical ideology being pushed
on the military and stated quote the
diversity inclusion and equity industry
and the trainings we are receiving in
the military is rooted in critical race
theory he was relieved of his command
for this
hey all of this is deeply deeply
troubling stuff and again
remember joe biden thinks the way that
you compete with china is spending six
trillion dollars in a budget
and also localifying the american
military industrial complex
i think we are going to lose if this is
the way that you tackle
an authoritarian aggressive power like
china good luck
to you by the way just a quick side note
on the bizarre critical race theory
ideology and how stupid it is
there's this whole meme online called
people posting their l's
right people putting up tweets
describing things they've done that are
really just them describing how they got
their ass kicked online
okay so mark lamont hill posted a clip
of himself talking to chris ruffo chris
ruffo again doing excellent work over at
city journal
exposing critical race theory and this
really demonstrates
wholesale the perversity of critical
race theory thinking in which mark
lamont hill
engages routinely markleman hill is just
terrible
he was interviewing the he's
interviewing chris ruffo
and he says what do you like about being
white now this is a trap of a question
of course
because the real answer to this is i
don't understand what my race has to do
with anything
my race doesn't dictate my culture my
race does not dictate
my abilities my race does not dictate my
priorities
but marklemon hill wants to trap chris
ruffo because chris ruffo says
that i'm not proud of being white then
michael mount hill goes well why not
why not what are you guilty for and if
he says well here's the thing i'm proud
of being white about
then he says ah look at you you racist
right this is the trap this is the
catch-22 chris ruffo refuses to fall for
and marco manhill is proud of himself
for asking this dumb question
christopher what do you like about being
white what would you say
i don't know i again it's such an
amorphous term it's like a census term
or a
can can you can you do me indulge me
indulge me for once
just we're running out of time indulge
me for a minute i understand you see it
as as all these things but
you surely recognize that the world sees
you as white you know the world reads
you as white
and if you were to ask me some things i
like about being black i could talk
about cultural norms i could talk about
tradition i could talk about
the kind of commonalities i feel around
the diaspora if i were to ask you what
particularly if you're saying whiteness
is a thing that is being constructed as
negative and shouldn't be
name something positive that you like
about being white
okay and and chris ruffo rejects the
premise but marklein hill can't
understand why he should reject the
premise okay first of all it is
absolutely reductionist
to say what i like about being black is
all of these
various characteristics that really
don't have to do
with race and really have more to do
with culture and history
right like you can be black and and
agree with none of the things that
markline hill said there but again this
racial reductionism is now being taught
in america's military
settings i mean this is this is madness
now speaking of america's unreadiness to
face down china
the continuing the continuing failures
of the biden administration to face down
china
are becoming clearer and clearer to the
point where biden is having to back down
on some of them we'll get to that in
just
one second first let's talk about the
differences between like a regular chair
and the greatest of all chairs i of
course i'm talking about
the x chair okay so a regular chair you
know i'm in a regular chair right now i
got to tell you it's not super
comfortable
right it's kind of like not great on my
lower back it's not ergonomic i kind of
get up later and i have to stretch
the extra it's like sitting in heaven
it's like sitting
on a magical cloud of joy that's how
good the x-chair is
it's unbelievable the secret was not
only their patented dynamic variable
lumbar support which offers unbelievable
lumbar support to your lower back
now thanks to the new xhmt technology
you can also get heat and massage
therapy
while you are sitting at your desk i
mean this is luxurious stuff
instead of your old uncomfortable office
chair now you can look forward to
spending hours sitting
in the ultimate therapeutic massager
again it's like
angels are massaging you while you sit
and do your work
the xhmt delivers heat and massage
technology right to your core
helping increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy all perks that make
working from home or the office
a joy it's like if god would have
created a chair
like just directly created the chair not
the materials for you to create training
if god had made the chair would look
like the ex chair xchair is on sale
right now
for a hundred dollars off go to exchair
shapiro.com right now really is that
good
that's the letter x chair shapiro.com or
call one eight four four four x chair x
chart has a 30-day guarantee of complete
comfort you can finance your purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month go to
ex-chairshapiro.com right now use code
x-wheels
for free x-wheel blade casters so you
don't end up like scratching up your
floor
xchairshapiro.com that's
xchairshapiro.com
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
the biden administration
in a strange shift with regard to the
lab leak theory we'll get to that in a
second first if you've been putting off
throwing your name in the mix to win a
trip to our daily weather studio and
meet candace owens
here's your final warning like this is
it right now sign up as a daily wire
member with code vip
get 20 off your new membership be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip
to the daily wire studios to see candace
live the sweepstakes ends on monday may
31st
time is running out i mean look at your
calendar folks not only will you be
meeting candace you'll be getting an
inside look at her studio and let me
just tell you i'm very jealous of
candace's studio
front row seats to watch her take down
leftist live and in action on her talk
show candace
you're not gonna get another chance so
don't sleep on it go enter now to win
two vip tickets to candace at
dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off
again that's dailywire.com
subscribe use that code vip you get 20
off and a chance to win two vip tickets
to go see candace's show
it's not gonna get better than this go
check it out right now you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile remember that time
that um joe biden and his team
were saying that this lab league theory
like they're trusting the who to pursue
it
like remember that cause that was
yesterday literally yesterday well then
news broke from cnn that the biden
administration had shut down
a state department effort launched late
in the trump administration to prove
that covet 19 originated in a chinese
lab over concerns about the quality of
its work
that is why cnn reports that's the
quality of the work that's a problem not
the lab leak theory itself now the real
the reality is the biden administration
shut down that investigation because it
was a point
of faith for the left that the lab
leaked theory was not true
and it was a point of faith for two
reasons one because it was racist
racist to suggest that perhaps
the lab leak was the response and what
was the responsibility of the chinese
government
that this had been developed in a
chinese lab and then released that that
would have been
racist to point out and to trump talked
about it right those are the two reasons
why you could why this had to be shut
down
now it's very weird that people
considered it
more racist to talk like people on the
left today consider it more racist to
talk about the lab league theory
than to talk about chinese people
randomly eating bats
confusing to say the least but you know
they've got their ways but if you think
i'm joking about this whole racist thing
let me point you to a new york times
coveted reporter
who tweeted yesterday quote someday
we'll stop talking about the lab league
theory and maybe even admit it's racist
roots but alas
that day is not yet here that is a
reporter for the new york times on covid
trust your media your media have your
best interest at heart they care only
about pursuing the facts
the fact an apple is an apple a banana
is a banana and a lab leak theory
is racist if the new york times says it
so okay so anyway the biden
administration
shut down mike pompeo's investigation
into the origins of the virus
those involved in the previously
undisclosed inquiry which was launched
last fall by allies of pompeo say it was
an honest effort to pro but many
initially dismissed
that china's biological weapons program
could have had a greater role in the
pandemic's origin in wuhan
according to two additional sources okay
but
then it was mired in internal
politicization about whether this was
cherry picked by trump because
everything trump did was bad according
to the left and therefore even
investigations into baseline facts
that was bad too and by the way the
original investigation was fully
justified
why because everybody at the who which
is a deeply corrupt organization
a profoundly corrupt organization they
just took china's word for it from the
beginning
in the in late january the who released
a statement saying there was no human to
human transition
of covid okay and and there were like
hundreds of people thousands of people
running around in wuhan transmitting it
to each other at the time
if if the information we have is correct
this thing was probably out of a virus
in november
i mean the who lead investigator admits
they took china's word for everything
so of course pompeo needed investing of
course the united states needed its own
investigation
and yet yesterday you had gen saki and
company say well you know there is an
international investigation led by the
exact same people
who just played second place in the
human centipede to the chinese
government
here's the who lead investigator
we met with them we said do you audit
the lab
and they said annually did you audit it
after the outbreak yes was anything
found
no do you test your staff yes no
you're just taking their word for it
well what else can we do
there's a limit to what you can do and
we went right up to that limit we asked
them tough questions
they weren't vetted in advance and the
answers they gave
we found to be believable um
correct and convincing oh really because
um you also found it believable correct
and convincing there was no human human
transmission of covet 19 and thus it was
not any sort of global threat
in late january so yes i don't believe
you guys and i think that you are just
bags of tools like large bags of tools
that's what you will okay so joe biden
got hit with this headline yesterday
which is that
his administration had shut down an
american intelligence investigation
into the origins of coven 19. and joe
biden started to back up as quickly as
he could without tripping over his feet
and falling over and breaking a hip
he immediately started back pedal he put
out a statement
i've now asked the intelligence
community to read a bubble
their efforts to collect and analyze
information that
could bring us come on man closer to a
definitive conclusion
and to report back to me in nine
memorabilian days
now i'll read the rest in english as
part of that report i've asked for areas
of further inquiry that may be required
including specific questions for china
i've also asked that this effort include
work by our national labs and other
agencies of our government to augment
the intelligence community's efforts and
i've asked the intelligence community to
keep congress fully apprised of its work
oh weird so you mean the same day cnn
revealed that you shut down an
investigation you asked the intelligence
community to perform an investigation
amazing amazing meanwhile literally the
same day
the white house spokesperson jean-pierre
she was asked about
you know finding out the truth and she
says well we'll just have to ask china
to cooperate i mean that's that's worked
in the past hasn't it
china's super cooperative when they're
stealing our technology and invading
hong kong
and threatening taiwan and unleashing a
virus on the world that kills two
million people
but other than that they're super
cooperative
why do we think that china would
cooperate you know this is uh this is
something that you have to ask the
chinese government
right this is something that should be
important it should should matter to
them
but this is a question for how is that a
question for them specifically asked or
made this ask of president xi
of china for their cooperation in this
effort i'm not going to go into
uh details of private conversation that
the president uh
may have may have had with with
president xi she can't even commit that
biden's going to ask the chinese to
cooperate
by the way that's not a question for the
chinese we know they're not going to
cooperate the question is what sort of
leverage are you going to bring to bear
to get china to cooperate that's not a
question for the chinese
why would why would an american media
member go ask the chinese government if
they're going to cooperate in an
internal investigation
as to whether they unleashed a virus
that killed two million people
why unbelievable okay and meanwhile
this white house spokesperson then she
was asked you know if it turns out that
china actually this did
emerge from a chinese lab and not only
that that they lied about it all the way
from november
to the end of january a three-month
period
in which the world could have been
developing a covet vaccine and shutting
down travel
if that happens what sort of penalties
will there be and she's like well maybe
none
guys don't worry joe biden really wants
to compete with china by blowing out our
spending and syncing our economy by
wokifying the military and by never
holding china's feet to the fire on a
single damned thing
here we go in terms of you know
cooperating with the who investigations
there's nothing new for the white house
in terms of encouraging china or
penalties for china it does not um
cooperate with investigations going
forward i i i'm not going to
prejudge or you know make any
pre-announcements at this time we're
going to go with the 90-day
investigation
and see where it takes us from there
okay but again the 90-day investigation
is going to be reliant on people talking
to the chinese
this is like it's unreal so they're not
even going to be penalties for them not
cooperating with the investigation
yeah there's a there's a hardcore they
want to find they want to get to the
bottom of this thing
they're deeply invested in getting to
the bottom of this thing the truth is
the democrats want to put kovid behind
us in terms of his origins so they don't
have to face up to a couple of things
one
their complete battery of the actual
lockdowns in the united states
and their masking policies and all of
the idiocies that they've pushed over
the course of the last year and also
they don't want to face up to the fact
that they might actually have to get
confrontational with an authoritarian
communist state
meanwhile anthony fauci again i mean a
lot of back paddling happening this week
anthony thatcher was asked by senator
john kennedy of louisiana
about american money going toward
chinese gain and function research
and found she admits oh yeah by the way
the chinese could have like that could
have been funded by
us maybe you gave them money and you
said don't
do gain-to-function research correct and
they said we won't
correct and you
have no way of knowing whether they did
or not except you trust them
is that right well we generally always
trust the grantee to do
what they say and you look at the
results have you ever had a granting lie
to you
i cannot guarantee that a grantee has
not lied
to us because you never know
um well then why would you give money to
the chinese government
they're a communist state what are you
doing and
there's no such thing as trust but
verify for these folks they just want to
work with china
and that means that you're just gonna
have to trust them in the same way that
we're just gonna have to trust the
iranian government with money
they won't use it for terror no they
promised they said right to us they're
not oh wait hold on they're building
ballistic missiles now
you say sure i mean we have to give
money to gaza
in order to rebuild and for sure listen
we have
promises that this is not going to be
used for more rockets and oh wait they
did what with the money
you mean that if we give money to a
chinese laboratory
which is a black box because we have no
idea what they're doing there
that that might be used in ways
shocking money is fungible no
no okay but the media have a comeback to
all of this they spend a year
on social media literally shutting
people down who talked about the lab
league theory
facebook shut it down fact checkers
called it absolutely false it just shows
you how corrupt the media are how
corrupt the fact checkers are they're
not fact checkers they're conservative
sensors that's all they are they're just
anti-conservative centers these fact
checkers like politifact
and fact checked out or garbage
organizations all the way through
meanwhile your mainstream media tell you
that their dereliction of duty
and never investigating any of this
they're like well you know what of
course we couldn't investigate this
because
trump said it so if trump said it was
totally false obviously
so here is unbelievably
andrew cuomo talking about how the big
problem here is trumpers
they keep playing up the wuhan lab
league
theory they just they they keep playing
it up and that's the problem here
an intel report determined several
researchers at the wuhan
institute of virology were hospitalized
for an unknown illness in november 2019
the month before china reported its
first covid case
suspicious so why is it politically
charged
because trumpers who were complicit in
playing down the pandemic reality in
america
are now seeing more interest in the
china lab
theory as some kind of vindication
enough to play i told you so with
fouching
well i mean what if fauci was not
telling the truth what if like why is it
that the underlying story
this is always the way the media treats
this stuff right it is not that the
underlying
when it's a good story for republicans
or bad for the democrats then the story
is republicans pounce on the story
when it's a bad story for republicans
the story is the story when it's a bad
story for democrats the story is
republicans pounds
right when anti-semitism in the streets
of new york is emanating from the
radical left and their allies in the
pro-palestinian movement
then the story is republicans pounce on
anti-semitism according to michelle
goldberg
and meanwhile sarah haynes on abc's the
view she says that the real problem here
is that the lab leak theory is racist
again this is insane this is insane why
can't we have a
buy poll data americans understand
china's problem why can't we have
bipartisan agreement
that china should pay for the unleashing
of a virus
that killed two million people honestly
honestly i don't understand why this is
remotely controversial
i know many democrats in legislative
positions who full-on agree with this
but because trump said a thing you have
to oppose the thing so here's sarah
haynes on abc news
suggesting that trump's racism is what
buried the wuhan lab leak message
i think the messenger matters i think
during that time when
that theory started to be told it was
buried in an administration and a former
president who often kind of troped in
uh kind of racist terms and dog whistles
and so
it buried the message that could have
been actually reasonable but no one was
going to hear it
because it came from under trump's
administration and
the media at that time was used to what
he doled out
and they were going to push back on that
and unreal so
because they had to push back on trump
and that was the most important thing
because what our media became
as arms of the democratic party was an
anti-trump machine during the trump era
not an investigative reportorial regime
uh
an amazing amazing thing meanwhile by
the way how corrupt are our media
well it turns out the china state media
paid 1.6 million
for advertising from american media
outlets including time magazine the la
times in the financial times
according to mediaite the cash china
daily forked over included 272 000
to the la times 291 thousand dollars to
foreign policy 371 thousand dollars to
the british financial times
330 000 the canadian globe and mail and
700 thousand dollars to time magazine
that figures those figures come after
several large publications including the
new york times wall street journal and
washington post
ended advertising agreements with the
newspaper last year
by the way is it any coincidence that um
the vast majority of this money
as far as i'm aware was going toward um
toward left-wing
media outlet i i find that utterly
unsurprising
in the extreme meanwhile speaking of
america being weakened from within so
the the department of homeland security
head alejandro mayorkas
he is now admitting that too many
illegal immigrants are being admitted
into the country for us even to track
them
these things are going really well swell
under the bible what if we spend some
more money would that solve it maybe
you know let's try it here's alejandro
mayorka's admitting we have too many
illegal immigrants in the country for us
even to track them
i am not aware of the fact that um
we have the tools resources and
capabilities
to track with the more than 11 million
unlawfully present individuals in the
united states
which speaks to the fundamental broken
system
and the need for immigration reform oh
so i mean
you know what we're not doing our jobs
so that means that we need you to pass
legislation that allows us to not do our
jobs
excellent excellent bite administration
policy right here
by the way alejandra marcus also said
that diminishing the ability of ice to
do his job is better for public safety
so um yeah things are things are going
just fabulously well
is that the intended outcome of the
various orders
and directives a near stop of all
immigration
violation arrests are law enforcement uh
effectiveness is not a quantitative
issue uh it is a qualitative one
the question is as to whom
are we dedicating our resources
what will deliver the greatest public
safety results
for the american public man i love that
i love when he's like
quantitative numbers we can't we can't
measure law enforcement in numbers
we can measure it in feelings in
feelings if the feelings meter goes up
that means law enforcement's doing a
great job but the feelings meter goes
down
that means that law enforcement's doing
a bad job we can't gauge whether law
enforcement's doing a good job by you
know how many criminals that are us
no only the feelings ometer can tell us
whether we are doing a good job or not
you elected this you bought the ticket
we all take the ride gang
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
heron makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show